[Music]
>> I'm Alicia from the Machine
Teaching Group, and this is
Johan.
So there's an increasing demand
for ML models.
And we see this demand because
there are lots and lots of tasks
in our daily lives that could
benefit from machine learning.
And we think that this
increasing demand cannot be met
with just developing the machine
learning algorithms and focusing
on that problem.
So what we're doing is focusing
on something called machine
teaching.
So that's making teaching
machines easy, fast and
accessible for anyone.
And we want to increase the
efficacy and the productivity of
the teachers giving the learners
the ML algorithms.
So we take our inspiration from
software engineering, and
there's a lot of different
concepts that can be applied in
this space.
So what we're going to show you
today is PICL, or the Platform
for Interactive Concept
Learning, which demonstrates
these principles in a Web-based
UI, and it allows one person
with just domain knowledge about
how to build, or about
addresses, to build an actual
address extractor from text
documents.
So I'll hand it off to Johan and
let him show you how to do that.
>> Okay.
So this is our tool PICL.
So we're going to go through how
to build an address extractor
using PICL.
So the first thing I'll do, I'll
open a project that I started.
So I'm going to go into some of
the details of each of the UI
elements as we go along.
But briefly, on the left, you'll
see an area where we can see
existing labels as we start
adding them.
In the middle is our kind of
exploration pane where we see
the examples of data as we
explore the dataset.
The entities pane is as
describing what is the data that
we're trying to extract.
The explanation pane, this is
where we are explaining the
features that's important for
the model to learn.
So the first thing you'll be
able to when we want to build
any kind of model is to find
some positive examples.
So we can do this, for example,
by just doing a plain search.
For addresses we might want to
search for say pine street.
So we're going to search for
some example of an address.
We see at the bottom here it
found an address.
And now, because of our schema
we defined ourselves, we are
going to label this particular
example as being an address.
And I see it occurs here as
well.
So it's labeled that as an
address.
Now our schema we said basically
an address is something that has
a street, has a P.O. Box, it has
a city, a state and a zip code.
So we want to explain this to
the model by labeling all the
subparts as well.
So we'll label this part as
street.
We'll see this happened here as
well.
City.
Seattle.
You'll see that as we label
something as a street, we
implicitly label the street as
not being a city.
The state is Washington.
And here we don't have a zip
code, but here we do have a zip
code.
So that's good.
So as we submit our label, we
can now start training our
model.
And you'll see now in our label
pane we can see some of the
examples appearing here.
So this section here is an
example of features.
So this is where we explain to
the system why do we think this
an example is an address or why
it's part of an address.
For example, we could have
something like address words.
So if you see words, like words
that may be an address, contact
or location, this gives us some
clue of whether it is or why it
is an address.
I'm going to move towards a new
model that is a bit more mature
that we've added quite a bit of
labels.
Actually, not that many.
Maybe 50 labels or so.
But it takes maybe 10 or
20 minutes to label an extractor
to get to this point.
Okay.
So here you can see many more
labels as you've added them.
The review model is what helps
us to debug the system.
So you can see a bunch of red
boxes at the bottom, a bunch of
green boxes at the top.
These are basically items that
we've labeled as being
addresses.
So this box is a place where we
said this is an address and the
red ones is where we labeled
things as being not addresses.
So these parts are labeled as
red because they're not
addresses.
The scale that you see here is
the confidence of our current
model as to whether it thinks
it's an address or not.
So ideally you want all the
green boxes to be at the top,
meaning that things we've
labeled as being addresses are
predictors as addresses.
And you want all the red things
to be at the bottom, meaning
that things that we've labeled
as not addresses is being
predicted as not being an
address.
As you can see, this helps us
debug and find problems in our
model.
For example, this one.
This one is being predicted as
fairly positive that it is an
address.
But we've labeled it as not
being an address.
So you can see here it thinks
this is a street.
It thinks my P.O. Box is a
street.
This is wrong.
Let's look at this one.
So this one, it thinks it's not
an address, but we clearly
labeled it as being an address.
Because it has a P.O. Box.
So this is part of the address.
Now, the reason it made this
mistake is we haven't added a
feature yet to explain to it
what is a P.O. Box.
So let's add a feature.
So we call this feature -- in
fact, let me just copy a couple
of words.
So we're going to take some
words that are related to P.O.
Box.
So there are different ways you
could write P.O. Box, P. Box,
P.O. box.
If you look through several
examples you'll see P.O. Box
being written in different ways.
So we add a new feature.
We call our feature P.O. Box.
And we add a couple of words.
And now we have a new feature.
If we now retrain our model with
this new information, we see
that it learns.
Now it correctly predicts our
P.O. Box and our data is much
better separated.
So using this technique we can
easily train extractors or
classifiers to teach a concept
using no knowledge from machine
learning but only domain
knowledge.
Something that is important is
having access to a large set of
unlabeled data.
You want to be able to explore
the unlabeled set so that you
can get some confidence that
once you've built a model you
want to go through this big set
of unlabeled data and find
examples to make sure that your
model is doing okay.
For example, if I were to sample
using predictive positives, I
should be able to find an
example that is being correctly
predicted.
So this, for example, is an
address, we've got my street.
Got the city.
Got the state.
It got the zip.
So the takeaways from this is
that basically one person should
be able to teach a system
without any knowledge of machine
learning or without being an
engineer, you should be able to
teach the system some concept
that you want to teach it.
And this knowledge should be
able to be transferrable.
So if I were to start building a
model, I should be able to hand
it off to Alicia saying you can
continue do go this.
Which is often a problem with
machine learning, is people with
very specific skills are not
able to transfer that knowledge
to the next person.
Also, we haven't really touched
on this in this particular demo
yet, but the idea that you can
decompose a problem to smaller
problems.
For example, if I were to
include something like a phone
number inside the address, I
could build a smaller extractor
that at first extracts the phone
number as part of my extractor.
So the idea to be able to
decompose a problem into smaller
problems and build separate
extractors and compose
extractors out of other small
extractors is something we feel
helps to scale with complexity.
We mentioned that being able to
explore a large set of unlabeled
data is very important to make
sure that the final model
generalizes to a larger set of
problems and not get kind of
stuck on a small set of training
examples.
We also feel that software
engineering tools such as
version control systems and
things we've learned from the
software industry, we can
actually apply to machine
learning to be able to share
existing models.
If I could quickly show you, for
example, all the labels and
features are actually stored in
text format.
And so in our project where we
added the P.O. Box feature, you
can see that this is just plain
text.
And so we can now use this
system such as Git or CSV or
some version control system to
get a version history of a model
over time.
And I can also collaborate with
other machine teachers and share
our models in that way.
So this is basically our
takeaway.
Thank you for watching.